[موسيقى]
البندقية هي بحيرة تتطلب
عبورها
للهروب من المركز السياحي والاكتشاف
لأنه بعد كل أصول البندقية موجودة
هنا بين هذه الجزر ،
إنها قرية بورانو
حيث تعد مطابخ ألجاتو نيرو
بأن تقدم لي طعمًا  الحياة على
البحيرة لا أعني الطعام فقط على الرغم من
أن هذا جزء منه
هذا ما يجب أن تشم رائحته كما لو
أنه يتمتع برائحة مميزة جدًا
ورائحة غنية ،
هذا عمل عائلي كلاسيكي
يشبه ماسيميليانو وأمه
لوسيا ووالده
روجيرا  كل الأطباق العائلية الجيدة هي الوصفات
في الرأس ولن تتذوق نفس
اليومين الجاريين الذي علمه
جدي الأكبر
أنا أعرفك ، نعم في النهاية أنا وهل
تعرف أكثر ما يعجبني
وأنت لا تتعامل معه
الناس كل يوم ، نعم ، كل يوم
عليك أن تبذل مجهودًا خاصًا ،
إنه بنك يتطلب الكثير من الشغف.
هذا هو رجل البطلينوس
[موسيقى
] وهو يأتي على قيد الحياة عندما يحين وقت
التحدث والحصول على السمك ، لقد حصل على ما هي
السمكة هنا لا يتوقف ، هل
هذا صباح نموذجي
لتسليم [الموسيقى] في البندقية ليس أمرًا طبيعيًا
تمامًا  تعمل ، إنها تقلق
الآن ، هذا هو القارب الأكثر مشؤومة الذي
يجب حمله ، نعم ،
يبدو جيدًا هنا ، إنها سمكة رائعة
هذه محار موس مثل أجيال من
البندقية ماسي هو صياد في
قشرة السلطعون الناعمة القشرة التي أوه نعم إنها
ناعمة  وهذا هو نوع آخر من أسماك ثعبان البحر
الطازجة ،
نعم ، السمك طازج جدًا ، لقد نمت
في البحيرة الليلة الماضية في معظم الأوقات ،
إنه إفطاري
[موسيقى]
انسى ما قالته والدتك عن تناول
السمك
النيئ والأسماك النيئة ،
هل يمكنك تجربة واحدة  سأحمل
طعمها
أن هذا جيد ،
ما هو شغفك ، أنا متحمس حقًا لمدينة
البندقية لأنني
أولًا أنا الأمة وأحب الحفاظ عليها
عندما ولدت في البندقية ،
ستعرف الجمال و  لا تريد
دعها تذهب ،
تريد الاحتفاظ بها كما لو
كان لديك كنز صغير ، فأنت
تغار منه وتريد الاحتفاظ به ،
لدى الفينيقيين قول مأثور
لهيئة المحلفين ebonky ، أراه في
الطريقة التي يتمسك بها بورانو بألوانه الزاهية
المباني الملونة مكان جميل
يُقال إنه الطريقة التي وجد بها الصيادون
طريقهم إلى المنزل من
خلال الضباب ،
وأرى ذلك أيضًا في وصفات البحيرة التقليدية
، كل ذلك في تفاصيل سكاكين السمك ،
هل تعرف مدى صعوبة شراء
سكاكين السمك ، نعم ارجع ارجع
لديّ سكين
سمك يريد ماسي أن يريني حيث
بدأ
كل شيء ، هذا جميل إلى أين نحن
ذاهبون بالمناسبة ليس لدي أي فكرة أننا سنصل إلى
أين نحن ذاهبون
الآن نحن متجهون إلى torcello
[  موسيقى
] جزيرة توتشيلو ، يُعتقد
هنا أنها أول مستوطنة فينيسية
تعود إلى القرن الخامس ، لذلك هذا هو
نوع المستنقعات التي كانت موجودة هنا من قبل
مثل الشقق المجنونة ،
لذا هذا ما كان عليه الأمر كله ،
كما ترون قليلاً  من التاريخ تقريبا مثل
مكان منسي ر  من المحتمل أن يكون
أقرب ما يكون إلى ما كان
عليه ، وهو عالم بعيد عن
الجنون السياحي الذي يمر عبر
البحيرة ، أحب أن آتي إلى هنا في
وقت مبكر من المساء في وقت ما عندما أنهي
العمل فقط لأخذ نزهة لطيفة
خاصتي واستمع إلى البحيرة ، ما تحصل عليه
من
ذلك يساعدني فقط على
الاسترخاء ويساعدني على التفكير
ونوعًا ما يشبه التفكير وهو
جزء مني تعرف حياتي اليومية
عندما أعود عبر البحيرة
لأفعل ما  هل
تأمل أن آخذ معي ، آمل أن تكون قد
تعلمت الطريقة التي نعيش بها ، فنحن لسنا تقليديين
لا يمكننا التعامل بالطريقة التقليدية
لأن البندقية فريدة من نوعها
[موسيقى]